-Our next guest
is a talented musician and actor
you know from the Showtime
series
"On Becoming a God
in Central Florida."
She stars in "Monarch," which
airs Tuesday nights on Fox.
Let's take a look.
-I hate that everything
has to be a competition.
I love Nikki.
-Well, so do I,
but what can I say?
People like a little
"Game of Thrones"
with their country music.
When your mama
won her first crown,
she sang circles
around both Reba and Dolly.
-I appreciate the support.
I'm going to go out there
and do my best,
but this is not a competition
and there is no rivalry.
-Her naivety is adorable.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Beth Ditto,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Beth, it has been too long!
You haven't been here
since 2019,
and then you were supposed
to come and you got COVID.
How was your recovery?
-I am -- You know what's weird?
You want to really know?
-Yeah, get into it.
-They told me I have eight
minutes. I was like, "Okay."
The funny thing
is I have this, like --
'Cause, you know, with COVID,
everybody was depressed, right?
Like, really -- I mean...
-Yeah, yeah,
I think you've nailed it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I'm very smart.
So, anyway,
but, like, it made me, like --
I came out of it --
Like, as soon as I got COVID.
And then I got better,
and it was -- that was --
All the depression through
the pandemic and isolation.
Look at how I'm sitting.
I'm like -- plbt!
I've got thighs that touch,
and so putting 'em together
is an effort.
And that's not --
I'm not trying to be funny.
That's just the truth.
-Okay.
That's good. That's good.
Back story.
-Okay. Thank you.
So, yeah, so it made me --
it made me --
I came out of it.
Like, after I got over COVID,
a couple days later,
I had this like --
I went and got my hair done
with my friend
because I'm cheap.
Ordered the hair on Amazon.
Just like this wig.
And that's not an Amazon
commercial 'cause -- But --
-By the way, if it was
an Amazon commercial...
-$90.
-...I think they
might have had some notes.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Who? Elon?
-Yeah. No. Jeff.
Yeah. Elon is Tesla.
-The band?
-Yeah, he's Tesla.
♪ Signs, signs,
everywhere the signs ♪
Y'all are young.
-Oh, my God.
That is Elon Musk in Tesla.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God!
So you come out of COVID.
-Yeah, I came out of it,
and I felt like myself again.
-Mm-hmm. That's good.
-Something happened.
Like, there's -- Did you have
that relief when you had it?
I'm sorry you had it.
-Uh-huh, thank you.
I did.
-That you got it?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, so I had that.
But then this thing happened
where I knew I was coming
to see you.
-Mm-hmm.
-And then that was such a joy.
And then, like,
doing interviews and stuff.
I just love people so much,
you know?
-It's really nice to be
back with them, isn't it?
-Yeah, yeah.
-It is really nice.
-I want to tell you something.
-Yeah, go.
-You listen to me.
-I am.
-Ya handsome little devil.
-[ Laughs ]
-I watch your show.
You know this.
-Uh-huh.
-I love television. I love it.
And during COVID,
I feel a little touched --
But y'all watch the show.
When you say, "We love you,"
to every--
I'm getting choked up about it.
I was always like,
"There are people
in their apartments right now.
There are people in their house,
they're isolated,
and no one is telling them
they love them."
You know, it's really important,
and I really mean it.
-That's very sweet of you
to say.
-Yeah. I'm lying.
[ Laughter ]
My PR people were like,
"This is gonna
hit the nail on the head!"
That's not true.
I never listen to them.
They're always like,
"Beth, don't say this."
And I'm like, "Okay!"
-You seem very PR-coached.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Everybody's like,
"Where is the real Beth?"
Hey. Can I ask you a question?
-Yes.
-I know you follow astrology.
You're into it, right?
-Oh. Am I queer
and from Portland?
-Whoo!
-Yes.
Can't sling a dead cat
without hitting a witch.
-Okay. So...
-You want to know a story?
-I would love to.
-Okay. Buckle up, baby.
-You know what?
I'm gonna just get rid of these.
-Me too.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Burn, baby, burn!
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay.
-What else was I going to say?
-Oh, you had actually offered
to babysit my kids, and then
I heard you babysat your nieces
during the pandemic.
-Doing your "researsh."
"Researsh."
-I've done my researsh,
as the French say.
-Bonjour.
We got a couple of French people
in the audience tonight
who are looking
for a place to stay.
Can they come to your...?
-Really?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It was a real --
Let's just say
it was a real classic
French moment.
Like --
[French accent]
"I need a place to stay."
[ Speaking French ]
Where to? Where to?
"Where to?"
What are you doing?
-No. [ Speaking French ]
-They're over --
You can talk to them
in the commercial.
-[ Speaking French ]
You can live with me tonight.
-Yeah.
[ Speaking French ]
[ Singing in French ]
-[ Laughs ]
-I just love music. I love it.
-You love music.
-You know what?
In the -- During the pandemic.
-Uh-huh.
-I just want to shut out
my little nephew Ian,
who's here tonight.
-Really?
-He's from the town
that my parents grew up in.
-Okay.
-80 people.
-80 people?
-Mm-hmm.
-And this is in Arkansas?
-Arkansas.
The oldest town in Arkansas.
-And I've heard you say
that Arkansas in the '90s --
-It was a cultural hub, honey!
[ Laughter ]
Let me ask you something.
-Sure.
-Do you like the smell
of dollar stores?
-I do. I do.
-I know where you need to go.
-Yeah.
My mom's house --
Hi, mom -- is --
I knew she became
a grandmother when --
She has so many grandkids.
-Okay.
-I knew she became a grandmother
when I walked into the house
and it smelled like
a grandma's house.
That's not
the smell of my youth.
That only happens when your
children give birth to children.
I swear to God.
-Oh, it does --
You don't -- It is not
that the smell preexists.
-Oh, no, it didn't smell
like that when I was a kid.
-Yeah. Maybe your nose changed.
Do you think that happened?
-You know what's funny?
Even before COVID,
I haven't had a sense of smell
in eight years.
-Really? So you kind of were
ahead of the curve with COVID.
-Listen.
I was.
-You were.
-I was. You're a trend-setter.
-Hey. You know what? Thank you!
-You're welcome!
-This is the respect I deserve!
-And we're running out of time.
-I know. I hate it.
-So I'm gonna ask one question
about your show.
-Yeah, I'm on it. I'm on it.
It's on Fox.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-I think there's a...
I don't know what more
you can say about it than that.
But you -- So you are a singer,
but you came from indie music,
you came from punk music,
and now you're playing
a country music singer.
Did you have to teach yourself
how to sing like a country --
I'm genuinely curious
if that came to you naturally.
-Well, no.
-Okay.
-No, I think it could have,
if it was coming
from the kind of --
Like, when I signed up
for the project, I was like --
I just want to say also that
whole clip was not about me.
It was about Kevin Cahoon.
And he is so incredible.
-He's a very good actor.
Very funny.
-Do you know him?
-No, but I thought
he was really good in that.
-He's an angel. An angel.
Paulie! Hi.
[ Laughter ]
Um...
He wrote all the material.
-Oh.
-Um, I'm so sorry.
-You don't --
-I'm like, "Waka-waka!"
-You never have to
apologize to me.
I look forward to this.
This is my -- You know,
this is a highlight.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it is --
-That makes me happy.
And I will babysit your kids.
-Uh, you will not.
-That Ramona -- Why?!
[ Laughter ]
I could -- This is what
I don't understand!
-I feel like if I told you three
things on my way out the door,
they would be out of your head
by the time
I was in the elevator.
-See, you know
what you're wrong about?
-What?
-Everything.
For real. I can remember.
I have an incredible memory.
I remember everything.
Ask anyone.
The thing is, you know, like,
I just really --
When it counts, I'm there.
-Okay. I believe that.
-I really am.
-You know what?
-I've been chewing gum.
We got to go.
-Yeah, the worst part.
-I gotta go. [ Grunts ]
-Give me your hands.
You guys, this is Beth Ditto,
everybody.
She is one in a million!
Mwah!
"Monarch" airs Tuesday nights
on Fox.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."
Look at her dress!